uh yesterday i didn't even get to this
because we were so busy with other
stories but this is a pretty big story
prosecutors in charge of the trump
criminal probe
have resigned they have resigned
um the associated press reporting the
two prosecutors in charge of the
manhattan district attorney's criminal
investigation into trump and his
business dealings suddenly resigned on
wednesday
throwing the future of the probe into
question just as pressure was building
on trump a spokesperson for d.a alvin
bragg confirmed the resignations of
carrie dunn and mark pomerantz two top
deputies who had been tasked with
running the investigation day-to-day
they started on the probe under former
d.a cyrus vance
and stayed on
done the office's former general counsel
argued before the supreme court
in a successful multi-year fight for
trump's tax records pomeranz is a former
mafia prosecutor brought out of private
practice to add expertise in
white-collar investigations and has been
questioning witnesses before the grand
jury brag spokesperson danielle filson
said we are grateful for their service
and didn't say anything else indicating
the investigation is ongoing but of
course many people saying okay the
investigation is ongoing but it is
basically over it is basically over
and now the right is saying this is
proof the investigation was bogus what
the right wants you to believe is that
the investigation into trump was
meritless and bogus and in protest these
two investigators quit there is no
evidence of that
there's just no evidence of that
what we do know with certainty is that
there is major hesitation right now from
any prosecutor to actually charge trump
so if we want to speculate a much more
reasonable speculation would be the
resignation is because the investigators
realize no matter what happens
trump's not getting charged
and they were sick of doing work that
they feel will be in vain again i'm i'm
saying
if we want to speculate
that's way more likely that there's
evidence against trump
and the investigators realized da's
never gonna charge what the hell are we
doing here wasting our time
but both are mere speculation we don't
actually know that either of those is
the reason and so we can only wait and
see if we get a comment
that being said
as i've said before
i don't think trump's ever going to see
a day of prison
and i don't think these resignations
contradict
what has been my position on this for a
very very long time years at this point
if you disagree let me know you can find
me on twitter at deepakman and i want to
remind you guys we have continued
coverage of cpac live through the
weekend through the weekend
and on tuesday we will be live at 8 00
pm eastern for joe biden's state of the
union address
what will he say about uh 2022 election
what will he say about the russian
invasion of ukraine what will he say in
general we'll be live and i hope you'll
join me on twitter
on uh youtube twitch and or facebook we
have a fantastic program for you today
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping